repertoire actually for someone so young
usually when you're younger you
specialize in one area and then you
slowly add new openings but Arjun can
play anything okay it's the Italian game
so this one could get very complicated
later could get very tense but we could
also see a very kind of slow maneuvering
battle this one is rich and full of
possibilities
one thing I was going to say Argent he
will find a way to mix things up he will
find a way to be aggressive and kind of
complicate things maybe go for the world
champion at some points that's
definitely something he's capable of
just right now after that first game
it's important that he just recovers
forgets and okay this last bishop move
we saw him employ a Magnus frowning
that's a bit strange we saw uh Arjun
employ something very similar to this
yesterday against Liam Lee
and it worked out quite well Magnus
however has come prepared and this
bishop move
never seen it before database also
confirms another novelty yeah
I mean I like the idea of waiting I
think that's a great
um
suggestion and what about this idea of
moving The Rook were there potentially
the idea of just pushing forward in the
center saying hey you've taken a move we
all like Square Bishop instead of
getting your king to safety Let's uh mix
things up the fact that he stopped now
for more than one minute and he hasn't
castled immediately that makes me think
that he's going to delay it as long as
possible probably commentators Castle
now but uh I think that's maybe the only
way to justify this last bishop move by
black and there we go he does retreat
he's going to wait he's going to see
what happens first and then that pawn
push the black Jeep on coming to attack
White's Bishop on the edge of the board
plan he should adopt and he's gone for a
flexible approach just developing the
night what do you choose a pair of
knights or a pair of Kinder buenos oh
I'll do the chocolates
the nights the night the night
and I'll try it I'll play you both over
the chessboard yeah and uh I I suspect
that Magnus is maybe gonna
Gambit the porn Okay and here it comes
find out because this point is attacked
three times remember we don't want to
touch it and Magnus you're right he does
get a bit of Pawn and what is the idea
here white if he captures this way guess
black can just take back
so uh we will find out perhaps how to
evaluate this position uh Arjun has
taken in the center and I'm expecting
Magnus to recapture cryptic tweet by
Peter heiner Magnus Carlson's coach
seven minutes ago well if jaino is
quoting it then it's probably in the
mainstream databases perhaps not on the
online database but uh well origin
actually because it feels like Black's
attack is a lot more menacing and maybe
easier to play however having said that
I really like his last move developing
the night and that night is getting
ready to spring forward and look at that
on the board the King has gone to the
left James and I asked him what it was
and he was like I don't know it's like
some Pan-American under Nigerian
championship
oh my God that's insane that the world
champion is not like too big to look at
any old tournament I love that this
white Bishop maybe you could still
consider it to be honest but
okay Magnus just takes a time out brings
this Rook across over defending his
Central Pawn
a bit odd I thought the black Rook might
start pushing kind of support upon push
later but
yeah still very tense overprotecting his
pawns and the Santa but uh okay wow
this is also a lot of fun when one side
just uh just lights the match and uh
lets the spark take over no he's trying
to start a fire against that black king
and I I was about to say I don't think
Magnus is going to grab a pawn he could
at least here have captured uh twice
this would have been very tempting to
some players maybe and gone on a journey
with his Queen but okay first of all the
queen would have lost protection of this
Pawn but even if this Pawn wasn't off
for grabs lines would open up towards
the black king suddenly the black king
not feeling comfortable at all Magnus
therefore just blocks things up and
pushes the pawn now it's going to take
quite a long long time to create any
open lines towards this piece I'm sorry
but I don't because it gets too mad when
he loses but my friend on the other hand
she thinks he's very handsome
yeah simply arjun's playing some great
moves the White Knight did jump in we
love that F5 Square we've talked about
it before it didn't get captured
whitesnite sits there nice and pretty
Instead The Black Queen retreated and
Archer now has placed a White Queen on a
good Square Magnus there frowning before
Crossing his arms that body language
tells me he's confused as well it's hard
to evaluate this position both sides
look at those four Knights as well
stacked up all four of them and it's
like dominoes somehow and uh just like
Domino's things could fall for one side
uh if they're just tipped over the edge
and right now bring the Rook across
Magnus looks surprised
do you think he's going to start trying
to attack I'm always going to trade yeah
white tonight was just too strong right
actually in the if we go back to the
current position on the board about Rook
takes Rook I was about to say he could
possibly be thinking about Queen takes
Pawn as well and he's done it on going
on the counter-attack but uh okay he
does this and then now surely he has to
step his King across uh you have to keep
this bishop you can't let the White
Queen in towards your king still quite a
solid setup actually these two pieces
defend
pretty well okay he does this and uh now
white regains the piece so white has
actually won a pawn in the process by
using his Queen and grabbing this Pawn
Magnus he's trying to compensate for
that by going forward
this game is short he's going to end
with a winner I just don't know who but
uh it just looks like chaos uh the
Knight is attacked now when the Knight
moves is Black's idea to stop trying to
push this Pawn trying to blow open the
position but I don't think he has time
because uh the White Knight is
threatening to go over to the B5 square
and here we have it the pawn has pushed
forward two squares away from promotion
get rid of it take it off the board and
he does so Anything Could Happen white
is a pawn up and has the double uh has
had has the bishop here so white is a
favorite uh Arjun just defends by
sliding his Bishop out very very logical
move if this Rook moves now it's going
to be ending Checkmate if the Rook
Retreats anywhere how is the evaluation
bar so far in the middle here I mean
it's just so unbalanced okay he does
play this move defending his Rook
entertaining us now the first game was
kind of strategic this one is just
I mean it's like dynamite this game in
classical play yeah I think at all
levels it tends to kind of uh Zone in on
that amount uh 54 for whites oh do we
have a blunder sorry yeah yeah we
absolutely do he's he's playing with
fire every guy see whether it's good or
not the evaluation bar tells us black is
winning but
how can you let the black queen so near
the white king look at the black queen
of night they're the ideal attacking Duo
the Knight is the only piece that can
move the way the queen can't and
I don't see The Knockout blow yet I must
confess but it looks scary
she finds it wow if he finds this move
he's doing the check mating if he found
if you played any other move he would
have been checkmated
wow uh you're thankful you're right this
Knight is coming in now there's also the
idea of some checks there's also the
Black Knight coming to take this Pawn
I think black can keep it simple now
there's still a threat of Checkmate on
the back rank but black can create some
Escape squares taking a night with check
and another check and
yeah black would win here because you
can simply take the bishop on the next
turn instead Arjun has gone to capture
the this Knight and Magnus he's gonna
deliver Checkmate it's Unstoppable now
Checkmate coming on this square or
Checkmate coming via the night on this
Square two threats and the white king is
doomed
everybody see shakes his head he can see
that he's losing game number two as well
is this due to some inaccuracies by him
or his Magnus again playing
incredible chess I mean we can't fault
Eric I see yes he blundered but it's
from a human point of view magnus's move
was just genius right yeah and to have
calculated that was such a narrow path
as well he forced Magnus to find like
three or four only moves to win anything
else Eric icy would have been winning so
he kind of gambled at Regency and didn't
pay off but
and was it that night move by Magnus
there and here we go wow Magnus Carlsen
is up by two points now in the final
everybody with the white pieces he loses
in 30 moves minus Carlsen is on fire